wh
me
ブーム
ん
はじめましてこんにちは私は現在高校2年生の16歳です
ちょうど半年前今年の5月に行われた
テレックスに行ってきました
それまで youtube でしか見たことなかった
レッドという空間を始めてリアルで体感したとき私は最高にわくわくしました
その時のワクワクを胸に今日はちょっぴり特別な自分に出会いたい
そんな思いでここに来ました
私には友達から言われるとすごくうれしくなる言葉があります
それは聞いちゃんってなんか毎日楽しそうだなという言葉です
この言葉のように今日は私から皆さんにプレゼントとして毎日が楽しくなる秘けつに
ついて共有できたらなと思います
それをワクワクの輪郭というキーワードを通して伝えていきたいとおもいます
わくわくの輪郭について説明する前に
16歳の私から皆さんに質問があります
今皆さんは親族以外に何人高校生の知り合いがいますか
また皆さんは高校生時代に何に大人の知り合いがいましたか
私は今まで本当にたくさんの大人の人に出会ってきました
大人からその中でをと中の人から名称いただくようになりました
もちろん名刺のような形の頃ない出会いもたくさんありました
しかし校講師である私を子ども扱いせず
尊重してくれた大人がたくさんいることにとても嬉しく思いました
では私がどのようにしてそのような音もの人と会ってきてまたなぜそんなにたくさんの
大人の人と出会ってきたのか
それについて話したいと思います
高校一年生の秋放課後
高校での繰り返された学校生活に少し退屈している自分がいました
月曜日は個分で始まり金曜日や数学で終わり学校が終われば塾に行くそんな生活です
また退屈するだけでなく
もったいないなぁ何かしたいなとも思い始めていました
そんなモヤモヤを友達に話してみたところその友達も同じようなモヤモヤを抱えている
ことに気がつきました
そこで私たちは3人でなんとなーく
学生団体というのを作ってみることにしました
するとそれを知った母校の中学校の先生が
今度面白い人と会うから良かったらおいでよというので面白い人ってどんな人なんかな
とワクワクした気持ちを胸に行ってみることにしました
そこで出合ったのは
ある会社の社長さんの清水さんです
清水さんは今度大学生向けのイベントをするから
よかったらおいでおくと当時まだ15歳だった私たちをまるで自立した大学生のように
尊重してくれる
そんな奥までした
大学生の中に私も混じってみたいなんか楽しそう
ワクワクするなという興味半分の気持ちで何なら興味だけの気持ちでそのイベントに足
を運びました
そこで私は人生を変える出会いを経験したのです
それはイベントにたまたまゲストとして来ていた
これまた別のベンチャー企業の社長さんである100000さんという方です
中馬さんは自分の人生について自分の退出していることについて本当に暑い3をして
語っていました
わがままであれ
ありのままの自分でいることの大切さを私に教えてくれました
この考え方と中馬さんの力強い言葉は今でもどうしても忘れることができません
今振り返ってみるとこれらのかっこいいと心から思える大人との出会いで私のワクワク
の林学会はとても広かったような気がします
なぜならこれらのかっこいいと心から思える大人は自分だけにしか見えない世界を自分
で理解しそれを相手に伝えることができる
そんなところに惹かれたからです
私はたまにふと思うんですもし中学校の先生に誘われたときにその場所は入ってい
なかったらどうなっていたんだろう
おそらく清水さんにも会えなかったしイベントを知ることもできなかったし
中馬さんにも出会うことができませんでした
この出会いとは面白そうだなーとワクワクする自分の気持ちに素直になって
イベントに行ってみたり社長さんに話しかけてみたりとすべて自分の子も動画旨いった
もの
そういうことに気がつきました
今私の話を中心にしましたが今度はもっともっと皆さんに自分自身のことについて考え
ながら聴いてほしいなと思います
今日から一緒にワクワクるんでー
バックワークルーティーンとはワクワクを生み立つサイクルのことです
これこそが私が初めにお話しした毎日を楽しくする秘訣であります
このサイクルに気づきワクワクの輪郭と名付けるまでの間私は自然とこのサイクルを
繰り返していました
でも自然とりか繰り返していることでもきっかけ
つまり流 t の一番初めはいつも同じであることに気がつきました
それは
なんとなーく行動してみるということです
行動と一言に言ってもここには少しだけ仕掛けがあります
それはいつもと違うことをするということです
私が感じた学校生活でのモヤモヤはいつも違うこといつもと違うことをすることでスッ
キに解決されます
昨日と同じ今日1年前と同じ今日
あれっなんかつまんないなぁってふと思う事ありませんか
これって毎日同じ道で家に帰りごとにているなぁって私は思うんです
だったらたまには違う道を盗んで帰ろうよっていうのが私の考えです
うぇい t の中で次にお話したいのは
人と会うということです
皆さん最近はじめましてと言った覚えはありますか
友達の友達に会ってみる
友達に誘われたイベントへついて言ってみる
初めましてというチャンスは意外と日常のなかにたくさん転がっています
このチャンスを放っておかないでたまには拾ってあげてみてください
ちょっとでもいいからいつもと違うところは一歩踏み出してみてほしいんです
自分にはそんな攻城力ないしちょっと難しいかもしれへんわっていう人がいたら
とっておきの練習場所があるので oc しちゃいます
それは今日のこのてデック2という空間です
初めましてをきっかけにたくさんの人と関わってみてください
人と会うそしてその人のやっていることを知る
ハマっていることを知る
視点を知る
その人にしか見えていない
世界を知る
そこで何か面白そうって思える話だったり
心の琴線に触れてくるものだったりなにこれって気になるものがあるかもしれません
面白そつまりワクワクする瞬間があるかもしれません
でもこれって百発百中じゃなくていいんです
先ほどとは逆に人と会って話してあんまりワクワクしないまま終わってしまうことも
あるかもしれません
でもあんまり面白くないなあんまりワクワクしないなぁって自分自身じゃ分かることも
とっても台数だと思います
なぜラナではないと自分がワクワクできるかワクワクできないかそれさえもわからない
からです
何だかそれってすごくもったいないなぁと思いませんか
こういった自分が多く開くするものやワクワクすることをたくさん集めてきて自分だけ
が知っている
自分がワクワクできるラインのこと
わくわくの輪郭うっと呼びます
でもこの輪郭はただの境界線ではありません
打つと粗糖という概念はないのですなぜならワクワクの輪郭の外側にあたる部分
この部分にも自分の多くは9できるかもしれない解消はたっくさん広がっているから
です
でもそれがまだわからないからこそなんとなく行動して人と会う
その一歩を踏み出すことが大切なんです
ではこの領域の先にあるものって何なんでしょうか
どんないいことがあるんでしょうか
そこには2つあります
一つ目は
自分らしさが見えてくるということです
なんで自分らしさがメールかっていうと同じ毎日を繰り返しているだけじゃわからない
を取らないだけじゃなくてわからないことにも気がつけない
そんなことが他の人と会うことで見えてくるからです
これは好きだけどこれはあんまり好きじゃないなぁとか
こっちよりもこっちの方が好きとか言うそういう自分だけの感覚っていうのがどんどん
見えてくると思います
例えば私の場合だとお話を聞く公園かよりも何か参加者の人と一緒に何かする
そういうワークショップ型の方が好きだったり
ずーっと同じ作業を繰り返すようにもいろんなことをちょっとずつやるのが好きだっ
たり
成功談を話してくれ大人の人よりも失敗談を話してくれる大人の人の方が面白いなあと
思ったり
人と会うことで自分が見えてくる人と会うことでどんどん自分が自分らしくなっていく
そんな感覚を日々感じています
人と会うことで今まで見えていなかった自分の職名を知れる
それってすごく素敵なことだと思いませんか
二つ目は
人ともつながりができるということです
人っていうのは本当に面白くて
人との出会いはまた次の人との出会いにつながっている
つまり終わりがないと思うんです
自分のワクワクの輪郭を広げていく中でワクワクルーティーンを何回も繰り返している
中で本当にたくさんの人に出会っていくことになります
もっと深めたい知りたいと思ったときに話はしてくれる人ができます
私の場合最近グラフィックレコーディングという
書くことで理解を深めたりそんな場を促進したりする手法にはまっています
私はグラレコのプロである音の人と出会ったのがきっかけでこのグラレコが私の
ワクワクできるものになりました
そしてその人とは今でも私の練習ノートを送ると感想を言ってくださったり一緒に
イベントを開催したり
こんなイベンターによって教えて下さったりしています
それからそれから今度は私がある蔵リコにハマっている事を知ったまた別の人が今度の
イベントでグラフィックやってようっていうふうに悟ってくださったりしています
実は私が今まで出してきたこのスライドもゆらーりこ風にアレンジしてみました
こんな風に人との繋がりがまた次の人とのつながりに繋がっていくんだと思います
つまりこの枠はクルー t には終わりがありません
わくわくの輪郭というのはずっとずっと自分の中で更新されていくのだと思います
もっともっといろんな人に出会ってその人にしか見えない世界を知って自分のワクワク
の輪郭を広げていきたいです
今はグラレコに最高にワクワクしているのですがもしかしたらもっともっとワクワク
できるものにリアいるかもしれない
そう思うとそれこそめちゃくちゃワクワクします
ここまで話してきてワクワクの輪郭というのがどんなものかわかりましたか
たくさん人と会ってたくさん自分でワクワクする
そうしたら自然と自分のワクワクの任斯うっていうのは広がっていくのだと思います
だからワクワクの輪郭が広がっていくことは大げさではなくこれからの人生を変える
きっかけになるかもしれないんです
今日のこの手で x という空間だって枠はとのリンかけを広げる絶好のチャンスです
ぜひ勇気を出して今日のどこかでアフターパーティでもいいので自分から話しかけてみ
てください
その際キラキラの笑顔と初めましての力をちょこっと借りることもお忘れなく
そしてそしてぜひ簡単な自己紹介で終わらず相手にしか見えていない世界を知って
ください
さあ一緒にワクワクしよう
ありがとうございました
[拍手]